you know one thing you know we often
cover you know on film Kurds and what we
often talk about you know one horror
story or another that comes up through
distribution you know and you have your
sort of your own horror story with the
way it was originally distributed you
kind of covered a little bit I just one
if you can talk any more about the
frustrations of the original release and
wake in fright and then maybe contrast
that with what's happening on with the
phone well I think if if the distributor
doesn't believe in your film and United
Artists didn't believe in it they
thought why should we spend money
advertising it we're never going to get
the money that we're spending on
publicity back and so it and if you
don't spend money in a film and people
that aware of the film it's it's
ninety-nine percent that's going to fail
and it is of course it's it hurts no I'm
a colliding is it didn't hurt it hurt
after all you spend over a year in a
picture and you give it all you give it
all and and and also it got good reviews
which was that I guess whether that
soften the blow I don't know like
Pauline Kael gave me a very good to do
with you the dough IM in film critics at
that time christopher isherwood the
writer give it a great review Rex Reed
chose it as one of the 10 best of 1971
so kept terrific reviews so i guess that
least baby feel a bit better but now you
want you on obviously you make a film
for an audience wrong audience to come
and see it you want to share it with
them and if they don't come it was so it
was a blow but of course i was i was
young energetic and i went gone on to
the next fellow we made and i made i lit
by little I made a westerner Gregory
Peck right afterwards and I made the
punishment that he covers right
afterward so I was hopping in one film
to another at the time so the Boone
heels very quickly or we got forgotten
but they're just ask are there oh well
yeah but I never thought it would ever
come back to life you know although you
know what would the other
thing that I've I was I was very moved
by was the support of the Australian
directors the Fred skep see Bruce
Beresford Peter weird the three grade 3
greats of Australian film making all
came to me afterwards late recently and
said you know we saw that film a long
time ago when you first made it and you
don't realize what you affected all of
us we all got inspired by you because up
at that time it's not you can't make
good films here you got to go to
Hollywood and some of you saw this film
it oh my god you can make interesting
films in Australia so it inspired them
and they all trace of it they all trace
rightly irani and they trace through the
Renaissance of the surrounding films to
my film wake in fright and so that was
very gratifying for me the thing way
back then I didn't know it but I had
affected what's interesting about
filmmaking is also the long-term
repercussions sometimes of a film that
you know not even aware of you know and
I found it very gratifying to date they
were inspired by it but but now and now
suddenly it's we have a distributor who
loves the film they love it and they're
going to not only going to show in New
York like you did last night but in 37
major American cities so so now I have
the audience but I never got the head
before it's going to go across America
Detroit Chicago you name it the Dallas
how would you see and of course it makes
next week in Los Angeles but you've got
to have the enthusiasm of the of a
distributor otherwise you're dead and so
do you feel like with the original
relief that you should have been more
part of the release or is distribution
is that it's just something that's just
left the distributors and have you had
any more involvement with the current
release well yeah that the the current
draft rouse the current distributor of
the film they brought me to New York
they think that they laid on endless
number of interviews on television on
newspapers and magazines a radio and of
course that'll that'll helps with the
film's brought to attention and this
time they when it got good reviews a
broadcaster probably put it you know
they use them in the advertising quotes
from martin scorsese and the sunday
sunday New York Times Rex Reed they used
to impose those and another and other
and other reviews so if you have that
enthusiasm people who they tried to
bring the audience the attention of
people in New York to come and see the
film so it's so far it's been sold out
ok now for anything more can you David
and how many screenings will you attend
are you only attending screenings in Los
Angeles or or do you have plans that to
go some to some other cities no I did
the first two screenings in New York I
mean the first 273 to 730 screenings
yeah I'm Friday last friday and saturday
and i did a introduction and nutty of
the Q&A afterwards and we're going to do
two here in in los angeles nicks october
the 19th friday and saturday the
twentieth i'm gonna do the same thing
introduce the film and answer any
queries and people discuss the film so
far there's been AI has a request to go
to Detroit and Chicago but listen if I
was asked I would go but because
obviously you I want to help the film as
much as possible
you